Let me tell you about my favorite method of all, called "Graph SLAM."
This is one of many methods for SLAM, and it's the one that is by far the easiest to explain.
Let's assume we have a robot,
and let's call arbitrarily the initial location x equals zero and y equals zero.
For this example, we just assume the road has a perfect compass,
and we don't care about heading direction just to keep things simple.
Let's assume the robot moves to the right in x-direction by 10, so it's now over here.
In a perfect world, we would know that x1, the location after motion,
is the same as x0+10 and y1 is the same as y0.
But we learned from our various robotic Kalman filter lessons and others
that the location is actually uncertain.
Rather than assuming in our (x, y) coordinate system the robot moved to the right by 10 exactly,
we know that the actual location is a Gaussian centered around (10, 0),
but it's possible the robot is somewhere else.
Remember we worked out the math for this Gaussian?
Here's how it looks just for the x variable.
Rather than setting x1 to x0 plus 10, we try to express the Gaussian
that peaks when these two things are the same.
If we subtract from x1 x0 and 10,
put this into a squared format and turn this into a Gaussian,
we get a probability distribution that relates x1 and x0.
We can do the same for y.
Since there is no change in y, according to our motion,
all we ask is that y1 and y0 are as close together as possible.
The product of these two Gaussians is now our constraint.
We wish to maximize the likelihood of the position x1 given the position x0 is (0, 0).
What Graph SLAM does is defining our probabilities using a sequence of such constraints.
Say we have a robot that moves in some space,
and each location is now characterized by a vector x0
and a vector x1, vector x2, vector x3. Often they are 3-dimensional vectors.
What Graph SLAM collects is initial location, which is a (0, 0, 0) initially--
although here it looks a little bit different--
then, really importantly, lots of relative constraints
that relate each robot pose to the previous robot pose.
We call them relative motion constraints.
You can think of those as rubber bands.
In expectation, this rubber band will be exactly the motion the robot sensed or commanded,
but in reality, it might have to bend it a little bit to make the map more consistent.
Speaking about maps, let's use landmarks as an example.
Suppose there is a landmark out here, and the landmark is being seen
from the robot with some relative measurement--z0, z1.
Perhaps I didn't see it it during time 2, but this is z3.
All these are also relative constraints
very much like the ones before.
Again, they are captured by Gaussians, and we get relative measurement contraints.
One such constraint is every time the robot sees a landmark.
Graph SLAM collects thosee constraints, and as we'll see,
they're insanely easy to collect, and it just relaxes the set of rubber bands
to find the most likely configuration of robot path along with the location of landmarks.
That is the mapping process.
Let me ask you a quick quiz that'll take thinking.
Suppose we have six robot poses--that is, one initial and five motions.
We have eight measurements of landmarks that we've seen.
These might be multiple landmarks. Sometimes the robot saw more than one.
The question now is how many total constraints do we have if we count each
of these constraints as exactly one constraint.